in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Mary are with us hey guys how are
you great how are you better than I
deserve welcome welcome good to have you
so where do you live New Jersey New
Jersey welcome to Nashville and all the
way down south to do your debt free
scream yes sir I love it how much of you
paid off one hundred and thirty five
thousand three hundred thirty-eight and
ninety-five cents
Wow very good I love it and how long did
this take you
32 months 32 months yes sir oh my
goodness and what's your range of income
during that time 117 to 155 thousand
very cool what do y'all do for a living
I'm a fireman and I have a doula
business okay and so what caused your
income to go up so dramatically during
that two and a half years we took your
recommendation and got a bigger shovel I
started the business took $500 out of
our savings doing something that I had
already done and just made it work very
good made some money what kind of
business you start I actually do
training for firefighters and EMTs well
there you go that makes sense
okay cool well very good job you guys
congratulations so what kind of debt was
the 135 thousand dollars my truck or
college we both have master's degrees
home renovations you know windows
roofing the whole nine dental work
dental work
mm-hmm okay did you sell anything big no
nope just download everything 130 you're
doing like four grand a month on this
average through the time that's Rowdy so
which one of those things that when you
paid it off you went I hate you people
I'm glad you're out of my life my
student loan yeah Sallie Mae no
hesitation give the woman an eviction
notice get the old woman out of the
house I love it how long how long have
you had those student loans long you've
been out of school 10 years Oh Lord yeah
it was time for her to leave she was
getting warts yeah unbelievable Wow
very very cool that's fun so what
happened how long you guys been married
seven years seven years so
what happened two and a half years ago
32 months ago they caused this change
she did I give her credit for it all
what you do what you do Mary well I got
tired of at the beginning of every month
basically you know stealing from one
place to pay another to get through the
very beginning of every month and
actually I was on Weight Watchers and
one of the board's they had a
financially Fat Tuesday and a lot of
people there were following the Total
Money Makeover I was kind of following
it watching it and then finally I was
like you know what let me figure out
what's going on with this I had gotten
started I got the Kindle book mm-hmm
read throat is actually the last thing I
paid for with a credit card but then I
was afraid to be that wife that was like
oh we're gonna do everything we're not
gonna buy anything so I kinda told him I
was like I'm doing this but didn't
really get too hard on him and then a
few months later somebody had his work
talked about Dave Ramsey he's like you
know I'm like yeah this guy I've been
following and he's like maybe I should
read the book I'm like yes you should
that's a great idea
peace University at home oh wow okay
that really got the ball rolling because
I was a few months in so I did a little
bit and then once he got on board it
just I don't say kept going quickly from
that oh there's a tremendous power when
you're working it together it changes
everything yes we can't talk to couples
enough about working together it just
changes the math but it also changes the
emotions and the communication and you
just don't feel like you're dragging
this thing whole thing by yourself it's
a big deal so Wow congratulations so
when you got sat down finally and you
had that meeting when you said okay
we're both all in hands in huddle right
ready break right yeah and you ready
said ready set go we're gonna do this
together we're gonna go completely crazy
we're gonna Dave Ramsey nuts on this
budget we're gonna knock this thing out
what since that meeting - now was easier
than you thought it was gonna be when
you sat down and looked at the size of
that mountain now you're standing on top
of that mountain and you've climbed it
what was easier about the climb than you
thought it was gonna be I would have to
say honestly at the end of the month
having the extra money that we pay down
towards the debt just looking at it
going
we could use it for a lot of other
things but we had our goal in mind that
we knew that we wanted to be debt-free
we have two little girls at home we
wanted them to live the life that was
deaf free yeah it made my decision real
easy yeah okay all right so putting it
on the debt felt like it might be hard
but when you look at it went oh let's do
it
mm-hmm it was easier because all you're
doing is following a plan by then yeah
it makes sense okay what was the hardest
part of the last 32 months when my
daughter was my first daughter was born
the plan was originally for me to come
stay home mm-hmm and for my other job
that I had before this business and I
couldn't do that because we looked at
the numbers and we're like it's gonna
put too far behind
mm-hm but to make the sacrifice to keep
working you know to be able to now
basically home with them while I find my
business no that's how long did that go
on from the time she was born until you
were able to quit 20 months okay
something like that and in the scope of
her life in the scope of your life your
survive mm yeah but at the time you're
doing it it's like the world's coming in
it's emotional yeah it's very difficult
to understand very cool you guys
congratulations so when somebody hears
you got out of that you paid off
$135,000 I mean that's awesome when
somebody hears that and they say how did
you do that what do you tell them the
keys are they getting out of that having
a budget and actually sticking to it not
just doing this figurative budget I hear
people all the time they're like oh yeah
I budget and then they're like well you
know that wasn't in my budget but I just
I needed it like no you didn't need it
you wanted it mm-hmm you have to decide
what that's all sticking to it things
part of the deal yeah that's that's a
big and what about you David honestly
it's the communication just being on the
same page mm-hmm if I had done my thing
that she did her thing we'd never be
where we are now yeah I agree
I completely agree well done you two
well we've got a signed copy of Chris
Hogan's number one national best-selling
book retire inspired because that's the
next chapter in your book now you've
lived like no one else to get out of
that now you're gonna live and build
wealth and give outrageously like no one
else so very proud of you too
congratulations thank you very well done
all right David and Mary from New Jersey
135,000
dollars paid off in 32 months making 117
to 155 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
we're dead way to go you two
that's just awesomeness right there very
very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show